were you always did you were you excited
about the things as they started
happening or was there a time when you
said uh [__] another guest star for this
when am I gonna get or were you always
kind of excited and eager and like
living in the moment you know I mean I
get to do this I always got to do those
guest stars and no listen there was a
time when when you're like no no I I
don't know that I ever fully
fully you know took those opportunities
for granted especially at the time
because I was trying to build you know a
you know a resume and also trying to
with a guest spot usually it was like oh
I haven't played this role before this
this might be interesting so as you know
and at the time it was really the only
way to Cobble together a year it was
like you want to book uh you know guest
spot that kind of thing I'll tell you
the most impactful guest spot that
turned into probably one of the biggest
opportunities of my life was was lost
you were a guest star last was last was
I'll tell you quickly how that happened
I my wife was a huge fan of the show I'd
watch the pilot and I was like cool but
I lost the thread so I stopped watching
you know a few episodes in but she was
like a devoted fan and then me too yeah
oh yeah and and uh a year and a half
into it and I like the ending I don't
care what people say thank you for that
I really did you and me both
um so you were along for the emotional
right exactly really emotional at the
end well there you go so so I remember
she said look and she was acting at the
time she goes if either one of us gets a
job on that show we're all going to
Hawaii if it's a guest spot we're all
going that's the rule and I'm like all
right Shannon all right fair enough sure
enough I got the I got an audition this
is uh the beginning of season three and
I'm like oh man and we had to go to a
kids orientation for uh for a preschool
for our oldest son and we're like I I
gotta do this this other 13 pages of
material like I'll never know this by
tomorrow
it's not gonna happen and my wife's like
look just don't say no anyway long story
short I looked at the
and then I woke up in the morning saying
there's no way I'm going in on this
thing and blowing my shot and lost and
it's not and then I read it and I was
like you know what the hell with it I'm
gonna go and I bailed on my kids uh
education
and I was like I'm going in this room
and I didn't know the material all that
I certainly didn't know off book I knew
the essence of it go in there but
usually I wanna I don't know how about
you I like to be off book look I have to
be off book I think you know you know
and the thing is it's I've talked about
this but it's not easy for me to learn
lines as fast as most people but I like
to be off book yes always always but go
ahead so you can relax and you can play
yeah you can truly be there of course I
I mean most actors do not all but most
and so I wasn't obviously and I go in
there and I and then I see guys who are
completely different age you know uh you
know uh erase everything you know types
and we're like wow this I don't know
what I don't know if they know what they
want necessarily for this role I was
like I'll just do my thing and I went in
there and it was one of those I'm sure
you've had these where you're like I
don't know I don't know what's gonna
happen and it it somehow comes together
in the room
doesn't always happen certainly not for
me but I was like I think that came
together I think there was some
connecting and I think it kind of worked
but you never know but sure enough I get
the I get the yes and I'm like yeah you
know and it was almost like that zest
commercial I had that same sort of
reaction he's like we're going to go to
Hawaii my wife's like where I'll go and
I was like okay oh yeah so we all went
for the guest spot sure you know did
this backstory for uh you know Elizabeth
Mitchell's character and I was like
that's it I'll never I'm not coming I
was in a backstory there's no way and
then I get a call five weeks later they
want you back on the island in present
time and that changed everything so that
there was an opera there was when they
said that at that point I was like what
does this mean is it one episode they
said no they just said they couldn't say
and they didn't know they didn't know
and they wouldn't give you a guarantee
of at least three no nothing it just
went I just went and I was like I'm not
gonna question this we're just gonna
we're gonna go with the flow and I went
and then I kept coming back and coming
back and then the role sort of is This
role that was shrouded in mystery and so
I benefited from that because it was
like well who the hell is this guy this
is weird it's such a cool weird looks
like he's got an eyeliner on uh you know
you hear that a lot because you have I
wish you don't understand you've got the
best eyebrows eyelashes I mean you're
just so like you look at your like but
you're striking but for me I have to
have my friend Joe come over I look like
an albino I swear to God you dark it's
my eyebrows all right when I'm on set
they have to do that they have to you
know I'm just kind of like the Plain
Jane here but anyway